it's like The Legend of David and
Goliath our tester Marta Scott pits
Daimler's smallest car a smart fortwo
against the company's biggest vehicle
the actress hey hey get your sardine can
out of the way he says testing the truck
he wants to get by Leah the thing about
in the smart it refuses to let the truck
by it's way too harmful for the
environment and takes up too much space
harmful to the environment takes up too
much space
yeah right that's mr. yabba of course
such a big truck needs a lot of fuel
when it's fully loaded the average
consumption is just under 30 liters but
if the cargo is taken into account it's
about a liter a ton though the actress
engines comply with the latest hero six
emission standard and a truck like this
doesn't really block the road well maybe
sometimes but if all the trucks cargo
was loaded onto smart cars with their
maximum payload of 250 kilos each hippie
whole lines of cars taking up more space
on the highway and guzzling even more
fuel
okay all right so apparently the actress
is not as harmful as all that he
concedes but this electric drive smart
fortwo doesn't use gas at all four to
one it's electric drive they're
profitable Hopkins but yeah and that's
all well and good but what if you need
to carry baggage or transport good see
house himself Medina smart electric
drive missing a Peck Mitsu named h5 I
always take my smart shopping he says
I'm smart yeah unbuckle any buy two
bananas on an Apple there's no moral
foot in here at all to be fair the
smarts chunk is not that small it has a
cubic capacity of at least two hundred
and twenty liters enough for a whole
case of water and a battery charger
cable not bad but that's nothing
compared to the actress
it has two luggage compartments on the
driver's side
and another one on the passenger's side
there's also a great deal of space above
the front windshield over a thousand
liters in total and if that's not enough
there's also 30 cubic meters in the
cargo area per dammit
so the actual swings again theater that
macadam the driver tells the smart to
night way opening iron through my back
in the smart and it refuses pointing out
it's more much more comfortable to drive
a truck driver he wants proof we blast
the smarts interior has everything you
need for everyday driving a couple of
storage compartments bottle holder an
optional smartphone holder electric
windows battery level indicators a
speedometer and in the convertible
version a huge soft top
the smart electric drive is powered by a
55 kilowatt electric motor the maker
says it has a range of 145 kilometers
however the light windshield wipers
air-conditioning and radio which are all
electric powered can reduce the radius
of action in Germany the convertible
version has a starting price of 22,000
euros
but Gibson that's what are you yawning
for he asks it's great he agrees but
then offers to show off his work end
living space Tiger the actress has loads
of interior space
moreover the driver has a six-litre
fridge within range and a table can be
pulled out in front of the passenger
seat
and there isn't just one bed for a quiet
night sleep on the motorway parking lot
but too
there's an integrated level to help set
up the bed and even a reading lamp
the actress 1851 boasts 12.8 liters of
cubic capacity in 2500 Newton meters of
torque its 820 litre fuel tank and as
drivers to cover a distance of 3,000
kilometers without having to stop for a
fill-up
and in Punk'd or coilette and moreover
he says just in terms of coolness the
trunk beats the smart hands down because
it has two beds incorporated if he gets
lucky at a nightclub not early yeah but
I feel friendless to me but there's no
way this whale of a track would ever
find a parking space near a nightclub so
what's the point as a guy nice tough one
although the actress comes with all
kinds of bells and whistles there's no
way to beat a smart when it comes to
parking
and the smart has another advantage yeah
what exactly just follow me he says
there's anything like a son treat in a
battle such as this it's all about
outwitting the opponent not about who's
strongest or biggest
wasn't laws what's going on in our saw
what he had to do was fine the cork
there's two meter height restriction
yeah
once again smart isn't like the better
Carter
Lavanya says I'll show you who's got the
better car a lot you just need to move
it now
I like once an actress always an actress
so and yet spies I hope it's come here
here midday Mac honey there he goes
outsmarting the smart by getting an
actress into an underground parking lot